[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء في حصاد الليله
معكم حسن جامبو
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعلوا اخرى
البدايه من واشنطن وتحديدا من مقر
الكونجرس الذي يتاهب الانتخابات تجديد
النصفي في ظلي تارجح استطلاعات الراي
وتنام المخاوف من العنف السياسي
والى الخرطوم وترقب للمشهد السياسي بعد
تصريحات لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
وقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان قال فيها
ان القوات المسلحه غيرت مهامها لتعود الى
دورها الاساسيه في حمايه البلاد
والى ادلب في شمال غرب سوريا حيث سقط قتلى
وجرحى جرى قصفا لقوه النظام بالصواريخ قال
مخيمات للنازحين
والى بغداد هذه المشاهد من موقع انهيار
بنايه مكونه من ثلاثه طوابق التهمتا
النيران في منطقه الوزيريه وسط العاصمه
في مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
تحت وابل من قذائف المدفعيه والصواريخ
معارك طاحنه في بخمود شرقيه اوكرانيا
ومصادر روسيه تؤكد افتراب مرتزقه من وسط
المدينه
المواليه لروسيا في خيرسون تقول ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحشد اعدادا كثيره من الدبابات
والمدرعات
استعدادا لشن هجوم واسع جنوبي البلاد
محذرا من جهات تحاول لاختباء للعوده
للحياه السياسيه البرهان يطالب حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل والحركه الاسلاميه
بالكف عن استغلال الجيش سياسيا
وقيادي بالحركه الاسلاميه يرد فزاعه
الانقلاب لم تعد تفزعوا احدا واي انقلاب
لن ينجح ولو ايده الجيش كله
بعد اعلان رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني تشكيله
لجنه قضائيه للنظر في اتهامات عمران خان
له و لوزير داخليته وجينيرال في
الاستخبارات بالتخطيط الاغتياله زعيم حزب
انصاف يشترط استقاله المسؤولين الثلاثه
لضمان استقلاليه اللجنه
والحكومه تبحث مقادضه خان تزامنا مع حمله
اعتقالات قالت مؤيدين
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه
نقشنا تصعد المخاوف الاوساط السياسيه
الامريكيه بشان احتمال تاثير تسريحي الاف
من موظفي تويتر على الحد من انتشار
معلومات مضلله او مواد تحض على العنف
باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث
ما حجم التاثير او تاثير التراجع المحتمل
لضوابط تويتر على انتخابات الكونغرس
النتيجه جاءت على شكل ثاني نحو 46% قالوا
انه تاثير كبير في حين صوتا 26% بالقول ان
تراجع ضوابط تويتر سيكون له تاثير محدود
بينما قال نحو 28% انه لا تاثيره مطلقه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وفي نافذه واشنطن متابعه
الطاقه والبيئه قضيه محوريه في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس الامريكي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان نفتح الملفات الحصاد
متابعه تطوراتي في العراق حيث قالت وزاره
الداخليه امام لا يقل عن عشره اشخاص هم في
عداد المفقودين داخل المبنى الذي تعرض
لحريق في الوزيريه في وسط بغداد من جهتها
اعلنت مديريه الدفاع المدني عن اصابه نحو
20 من عناصرها في انهيار البنايه المكونه
من ثلاثه طوابق والتي التهمتها النيران
ونقلت وكاله الانباء العراقيه عن مصادر في
الدفاع المدني قولها انا نحو 50 فرقه من
فرق الدفاع المدني تشارك في عمليات اطفاء
الحريق المتوسط والذي تسبب في اضرار كبيره
في البنايات المجاوره وعدد من السيارات
القريبه من موقع الحريق
[موسيقى]
بمزيد من التفاصيل معنى من بغداد مدير
مكتب الجزيره وليد ابراهيم وليد ما الذي
جرى بالتحديد
الذي
جرى ان هو في تمام او في حدود الساعه
الثانيه عشر ظهرا بحسب التوقيت المحلي
لمدينه بغداد اي قبله 11 ساعه
بالضبط كان هناك حريقه اندلع في احد
المخازن قالت مصادر الدفاع المدني انه
مخزن همم
للعطور والمواد التي تستخدم في العطور ال-
ال- الحريق
ليصل الى محلات اخرى مجاوره والى بنايات
اخرى عديده مجاوره وانا اتحدث حسن اترك
الكاميرا ايضا تنقل ما يجري همم الحريق
الذي اندلع في المخزن امتد بشكل سريع جدا
الى البنايات القريبه من المخزن وهذا صعب
كثيرا على رجال الدفاع المدني الذين
يتواجدون حتى في هذه اللحظه باعداد كبيره
جدا صعب عليهم محمد او مهمه السيطره على
هذا الحريق هذا المخزن وفي هذه المكان
نتواجد نحن فيه منطقه تسمى منطقه الوزيريه
او تحديدا الحي الصناعي في الوزيريه هو
عباره عن مقر لشركات ومصانع ومخازن همم
للعديد من الشركات المحليه العامله في
العراق
جزء من هذه المخازن ايضا يضم مواد همم
قابلا للاشتعال وهذا هو الذي ساعد في او
الذي سهل عمليات همم انتشار النيران في
مكان واسع هذا بالتحديد هذه الصور حسن هي
بالتحديد المخزن الذي وقع فيه الحريق اول
الامر ليمتدي الى المناطق الاخرى همم حسب
همم العديد من العائلات ما زالت تنتظر هنا
اي حديث عن ذويها الذين الذين ما زالوا
مفقودين لا احد يعرف علىهم على وجه الدقه
قبل قليل تحدث مدير العلاقات في وزاره
الداخليه اللواء سعد معن وقال ان عدد
المفقودين حدوث 13 شخصا همم العوائل تتحدث
عن اكثر من هذا الرقم على ايه حال ال- ال-
فرق الدفاع المدني تمكنت من السيطره على
الحريق على الاقل حتى الان لا نعرف اذا
كان سيلعب مره اخرى ام لا لانني تحدثت قبل
قليل مع ال- مع الناس الذين يتواجدون هنا
قالوا انه في اكثر من مره يتم السيطره على
الحريق وتندلع مره اخرى سنه ال النار
تشتعل وهذا يعني ان هناك مواد
داخل المخزن ما زالت ما زالت حتى اللحظه
قد تكون قد تشتعل مره اخرى على ايه حال
همم الوضع الان قد يكون تم تسيطر عليه من
فرق الدفاع المدني لكن بكل تاكيد الحديث
الان هو ينصب باتجاه عددنا الضحايا كم هو
عدد الضحايا الذين سقطوا في هذا الحادث
حتى هذه اللحظه نعم حسن
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
محمود شرقا وخيرسون جنوبا منطقه ثاني لن
تكون معارك اوكرانيا فيهما كما قبلها
لروسيا صاروا على مشارف المدينه
الشرق والجنوب جبهه ثاني في اوكرانيا هما
الاكثر التهابه
المواليه لروسيا
عن قصف صاروخين اوكراني تكثف على مقاطع
التيار الكهربائي والمياه جراء القصف
واعمال
كما تؤكد ارجاء عشرات الالاف من سكان
المقاطعه
للامر حكما صله بتنبيه موسكو الى حشد
الاوكرانيين مدرعات على محور خرسون
يقرا الروس في ذلك تاهبا لهجوم وشيك يروم
استعاده المقاطعه التي سقطت في ايديهم في
بدايه الحرب ثم ضموها مع ثلاث مقاطعه اخرى
الى اراضيهم في استفتاءات سبتمبر المثيره
للجدل
هي احداث تلك المناطق وفي تقدمه البطيء
هناك تشكل مدينه باخ مورس الى الشمال
اهميه خاصه للجيش الروسي
يوصف محور مدينه باخموت بانه اعنف جبهات
القتال في اقليم دومباس خصوصا مع التمكن
القوات الروسيه من الوصول الى مشارف
المدينه
والمدينه الاستراتيجيه تكشف وسائل الاعلام
روسيه عن تمركز للقوه فاجنر على بعد
كيلومترين منها يقول قائد الميداني في
المجموعه ان قوته سيطرت على بلدتين
ملاصقتين للمدينه من جهه الجنوب لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول صدام
حسين الفا قبل بدء الحرب والان اضحك شبه
فارغه بعد ان اصاب الدمار معظم اجزائها
وبينما يستعروا القتال حول المدينه
المحاصره تتفاقم الماساه الانسانيه لمن
اختاروا البقاء او اجبر عليه يقولون انهم
صامدون على امل ان تتمكن القوات
الاوكرانيه من ابعاد من يص هم بالغزاه
معنى من بيروت العميد الياس حنا للخبيره
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد الياس
لنبدا من بخمون
هذه المدينه شمال الاقليم دومباس التي
يتاهب الجيش الروسي للسيطره عليها ما
اهميتها بالنسبه اليه
ااه حسن اولا هي كان من المفروض ان تكون
استكمالا لما حصل في سيفردونس جنس ولكن
بعد سقوط اعلن الرئيس بوتين الوقفه
العمليا
اوبريشن البوست كما يقال بخموت اليوم فقدت
بعض الاهميه بعد سقوط زيون بعد سقوط
كوبيانسك لانها على نفس الخط الحديدي او
سكك الحديد الاساسيه اليوم يبدو انا هذه
المنطقه هي حرب ممول شركه
له دور اساسي مهم جدا لانه مرتزقه قد فجر
هي التي تقاتل هناك وهو يريد تحقيق شيء
معين ولكن لا نفهم حتى الان بالصوره
الكبرى المكان الوحيد الذي تهاجم فيه
القوات الروسيه ما هو دور محمود في
استراتيجيه الكبرى حتى الان يبدو انه فقط
نصرا او يريد تحقيق يمكن
بريجوزين يعني هل يمكن ان نفهم انه محاوله
تعويض مسبق لما ااا سيكون عليه الوضع في
خيرسون الذي على العكس تماما تستعد القوات
الاوكرانيه للهجوم
في الشرق نشر ما يقارب 82 الف جندي من
المستدعين الجدد
43 او 49 منهم في وحدات عسكريه بدانا نرى
استعدادات مهمه ولكن كلها في حاله دفاع
اذا تم السيطره على مخبوط هي تحضير
المرحله القادمه مرحله ما بعد الشتاء لانه
اذا سقطت محمود المرحله القادمه هي يجب ان
تكون في الماضي في المنطق سلوفيانس هو
كلام هذا يتطلب جهود وتحضيرات تستلزم مؤقت
اما في خير سون فهذا امر مختلف جدا لانه
السيناريات متعدده النهر هو العاقل
الاساسي هناك عمليات استعداد اساسيه ولكن
هناك ايضا عامل الطقس بدا اا يضع اعباء
مهمه من الوحول وغيرها على القوات
الاوكرانيه طيب كيف يمكن هنا ان نقرا
السيناريو المتوقع
لشمال الخير سون تحديدا وخصوصا ان القوات
الروسيه يعني تعقد المهمه على القوات
الاوكرانيه اللوجستيا وحتى على مستوى ال-
كهرباء
والامدادات وامكانيه الوصول الى الامدادات
حسن النوايا مكبوته حتى الان ولكن هناك
مؤشرات عديده
تلغيم النهر ضفتين النهر
والاستعداد
لقتال تاخيري لاستنزاف قوات الاوكرانيه
ويبدو كما يقال ان هناك عده سيناريوات ان
يستنزف الجيش الاوكراني وتنصب له مكيده
معينه لاستنزافه واخذه من الجبهات الاخرى
او الانسحاب الكامل للقوات روسيه وانا
اعتقد ان هذه السيناريو ليس سيناري ممكن
في عقله الرئيس بوتين لانه لن يسلم مدينه
خرسون كما هي والحل الثالث الانسحاب
الكامل الى الضفه الشرقيه من النهر بعد
تحسينها وتكون هذه الخط الاساسي يمتد من
خلال سنن النهار حتى هاركاب او حتى
شكرا لكل يسحرنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي حدثتنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
غادر زعيم وحزب انصاف المعارض عمران خان
المستشفى الى منزله في لاهور بعد ثلاثه
ايام من محاوله اغتياله الفاشله وكان
عمران قد رحب بدعوه رئيس الحكومه شباس
شريف لتشكيل لجنه القضائيه للنظر في
الحديثه لكنه اشترط استقاله شريف نفسه
ووزير داخليه وضابه في الاستخبارات كي
تتمكن اللجنه من العمل بشكل مستقل على حد
قوله في غضون ذلك تبحث الحكومه
الباكستانيه في الخيارات القانونيه
الممكنه لمقاضات خان بسبب اتهامه مسؤولين
كبار بالتخطيط الاغتيال
تعلق باكستان في تداعيات محاوله اغتيال
رئيس وزراءها السابق
فالمواجهه بين السلطه والمعارضه بقياده
عمران خان دخل طورا جديدا من التصعيد بعد
ان شكك الرجل في جدوى لجنه التحقيق التي
دعا الى تشكيلها رئيس الوزراء لتقسي خفايا
محاوله الاغتيال الفاشله
ماذا ستفعل هذه اللجنه ضد المتهمين
الثلاثه بمحاوله قتل طالما هم في مناصبهم
وتعملوا تحت امراتهم اجهزه امن سيتعين
عليها تقديم ملاحظات لتلك اللجنه كيف يمكن
لتلك اللجنه ان تعمل باستقلاليه وشفافيه
والمتهمون يشبهون على عملها هذا مستحيل
لذا اكرر مطالبه باستقاله المتهمين
الثلاثه يتم اجراء التحقيق حقيقي
المتهمون حسب خانهم رئيس الحكومه شهباز
شريف ووزير الداخليه رنا صنعه الله وضابط
استخبارات برتبه لواء يدعى فيصل ناصر لكن
الحكومه والجيش
اعتبرتهامات خان مجردا كذيب وهدد بمقاضته
بتهمه التشهير
وبينما تتمدد الازمه الى قطاعات حساسه
بينها الجيش والاستخبارات كشف حزب انصاف
الذي يقوده خان ان السلطات الباكستانيه
اوقفت عشرات من مؤيدينها خلال مشاركتهم في
وقفات تضامنيه مع رئيس الوزراء المصاب منذ
تعرضه الخميس الماضي لاطلاق نار في مدينه
شرقيه باكستان وبعد ثلاثه ايام من الحادثه
غادر عمران خان المستشفى عائدا الى منزله
الىهور لكنه حرس قبل مغادته على كشف خريطه
طريق لحركته الاحتجاجيه المطالبه
راء انتخابات مبكرا اكد ان المسيره
الحاشده ستستانف الثلاثاء مسيرها نحو
العاصمه اسلام اباد
وسيقودها وزير الخارجيه السابق شاه محمود
قرشي الى ان يتعافى خان من اصابته والامر
قد يحتاج الى نحو اسبوعين على الاكثر قبل
ان ينضم خان الى المسيره ويتولى قيادتها
ثانيه عند وصولها مدينه والبندي على مشارف
مركز القرار في اسلام اباد
معنى من اسلام اباد ظفر جاسبل استاذ
العلوم السياسيه سيد ظفر مرحبا بك اي
تداعيات ستنجم عن هذا التجاذب القائم بعد
محاوله الاغتيال بين عمران خان من جهه
والحكومه
والجيش من جهه ثانيه
في هارد لاين قد بدا الان
يعتمدوا مقاربه
قاسيه ويصير في ماسار صعب يتهموا فيه
الحكومه
برئيس وزراء اياها اعتقد
ان هذا موقف متشدد من جهته
لانه بحسب
المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاهلي الجيش
السوري
ما حصل في الشهر الماضي كان قد بدا
يشكك في نزاهه المسؤولين العسكريين
والسياسيين اذا اعتقد ان باكستان تدخلوا
في مرحله ازمه سياسيه حيث ان القوات
الحكوميه والامنيه من جهه هي في مواجهه
قائد شعبيه محبوب وهذا مواجهه سوف تدفع
البلاد نحو الفوضى
ماذا تقصد هنا ان هذه المواجهه ستدفع
البلاد نحو الفوضى اذا اذا كان الجيش بقي
في صف الحكومه والحكومه على موقفها متحده
بمواجهه عمران خان من اين ستاتي الفوضى
الاستقرار بطريقه حساسه وخطيره و نعم صحيح
الحكومه موحده الصف
هو الجيش يدعمها
القوات المسلحه الباكستانيه
المتحدث
باسمها
من خلال قوى الامن ايضا كل هذه الجهات
تحاول ان تؤكد وتكرره ان الحكومه هي على
الحياه
توم برايم الحلقه
بعد الاصابه التي تعرض لها جراء محاولات
الاختيار يرفض تصديق هذه الروايه لهذا نحن
نقول ان الوضع
سليما لدينا الحكومه والمؤسسه العسكريه من
جهه في مواجهه
جهه واحده
بين الحكومه والجيش من جهه ومؤيدين عمران
خان من جهه ثانيه وهم ليسوا بالاقليه
يا ات مليتو
الى تقويه الاستقرار السياسي في البلاد
بالاضافه الى ما يمكن وصفه
بتعزيز الوضع الاقتصادي المتردي
[موسيقى]
الاستاذ العلوم السياسيه من اسلام اباد
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان القوات المسلحه غيرت
مهامها لتعود الى دورها الاساسي في حمايه
البلاد ويشدد على استقلاليه وحياه الجيش
كما حذر البرهان مما وصفها بمحاولات حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل والحركه الاسلاميه
استغلال الجيش للعوده للحياه السياسيه
من جانبه يقلل المتحدثه باسم الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي شهاب
ابراهيم ان خطاب البرهان حمل اشارات جيده
تستبطن الموافقه على مقترح الدستور
الانتقالي الذي اعدته نقابه المحامين
السودانيين
في المقابل قال القيادي في الحركه
الاسلاميه السودانيه امين حسن عمر للجزيره
ان فزاعه الانقلاب لم تعد تفزعوا احدا
ويؤكد ان ايام خلابا لن ينجح مهما كانت
الجهه التي تقوده حتى لو يده الجيش كله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا 48 ساعه تفصلنا عن انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس
على المشهد الامريكي في هذه النافذه من
واشنطن ال سي
شكرا لك حسن واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اذا مع اقتراب موعد الحسم لتحديد الخريطه
الجديده للكونجرس الامريكي بمجلسيه النواب
والشيوخ تظهر استطلاعات الراي المختلفه
احتدام المنافسه في الولايات توصف
بالمتارجحه بسبب تقارب حظوظ الحزبين فيها
نستعرض اخر مؤشرات المعركه الانتخابيه في
تقرير عبد القادر عراضه
في الانتخابات الامريكيه معني بها 35
مقعدا من مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ المياه وكل
المقاعد الاربع مئه والخمسه وثلاثون في
مجلس النواب ونذكر بان من بين المقاعد
الخمسه و 30
مقعدا بينما يشغل الديمقراطيون 14 مقعدا
وجميعها في ولايه صوتت لبيض عام 2020
ومع اقتراب يوم الحسم اظهرت اخر استطلاعات
الراي اجرتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست وشبكه اي
بي سي ان ثلثي الامريكيين يثقون بالنظام
الانتخابي في بلادهم وبانه سيتم عد
الاصوات بدقه وفق احدث استطاعات الراي
الخاصه بمجلس الشيوخ لموقع ريال
في خانه الولايات المتاحه بالنظر لتقارب
مرشح الحزبين فيها واذا حصل جمهوريون على
ثلاث منها فيرجح فوزهم بالاغلبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ نجد جورجيا وبها تنفس حاد وفارق
اقل بالنسبه
على الاطلاق يفوز بالولايه من اصول
افريقيه ومنافسه هرش الوكر وهو مرشح
جمهوري افريقي الاصل ايضا
بس الفيديو ولايه حاسمه اخرى وفي اخر
سباقين على الرئاسه كان الحسم فيها بفارق
10 اجزاء في المئه من المائه
جدا
وخصمه الجمهوريه مهمه اوز المعروف
بالدكتور اوس
لماذا ايضا حاسمه وقد فازت فيها النائبه
الديمقراطيه
عام 2016 كاول سيناتور من اصول اللاتينيه
على الاطلاق ويامل الجمهوريون في
استعادتها ورشحوا لذلك ادم لك سالت الذي
يتقدم بنحو نقطتين ونصف في المئه ويختاروا
ناخبوا اريزونا سيناتور لتمثيلهم من بين
سنه الديمقراطي الحالي ماركلي ومنافسه
الجمهوريك ماسترز في سباق متقاربين وان
كان يتقدم بنقطه واحده
جونسون لولايه الثالثه والتحقت بالولايات
المتارجحه ولايه نيو هامشر التي تتقدم
فيها المرشحه الديمقراطيه حسن بفارق ضئيل
على منافسها الجمهوريك بالنسبه لي مجلس
النواب وفق موقع ريال
يتمتع الديمقراطيون
147 مق متوقعه في دوائر تعد الديمقراطيه
صلبه او شبه ديمقراطيه او تميل لهم بينما
يتمتع الجمهوريون ب227 مقعدا وتوقعتا في
دوائر تعد جمهوريه صلبه او شبه جمهوريه او
تميل لهم وتنافسه في ولايات متارجحه
بالنسبه لمجلس النواب ظل في حدود اربع
وثلاثين دائره تعد متاحه وترجح صناعات
الراي تفوقا محتمله للحزب الجمهوري في
انتخابات مجلس النواب بما بين 10 و20
مقعدا ما يكفي لحصوله على الاغلبيه
ينضم الينا من المدينه لاس فيغاس في ولايه
نيفادا مراسل الجزيره فادي منصور مرحبا بك
فادي اذن استطلاعات الراي تظهر نتائج
متقاربه بين المترشحين على مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ في لافاده ماذا في التفاصيل واخر
المستجدات
تاريخيه هنا التي ترحب بالزائريينس مدينه
عاصمه الترفيه هو الرهانات والعروض
الترفيهيه ربما العرض السياسي الانتخابيه
لا يقل اثاره هنا المعركه متقاربه للغايه
وفقه متوسطه استطلاعات الراي التي نشرها
موقع ريال مدريد مع تقدم من طفيف نحو
نقطتين مئويتين للمرشحه الجمهوري لاجزالك
على منافسته الديمقراطيه السنه
ترديز ماستو هنا في ولايه نيفادا نيفادا
قد تكون همم احدى الاوراق الرابحه حيث
يراهن الجمهوريون على الفوز بها من اجل
تعزيز فراسهم بانتزاع مجلس الشيوخ من
الحزب الديمقراطي في حين يراها لحزب
الديمقراطيه على معركه يمكن ان ينتصر بها
الارقام متقاربه للغايه وفي حاله تمكن من
الاحتفاظ بمقعد مجلس الشيوخنا تتعزى فرص
الديمقراطيين الرئيس الامريكي بالابقاء
على السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ بانتظار
معارك الاخرى ما تتسم بهذه المنطقه حقيقه
نانسي اولا اننا عمليا انفارق عن الساحل
الشرقي نحو ثلاث ساعات وبالتالي نتائج
الانتخابات هنا سوف تتاخر قليلا وبالتالي
سوف يكون علينا ان ننطر لكن حقيقه هذه
المدينه احد معاقل الطبقه العامله
الامريكيه وايضا صوت التينو وتاريخيا
الديمقراطيون كان لديهم شبكه قويه همم
خصوصا من خلال اتحاد عمال المطاعم وهو
اتحاد كبير للغايه هؤلاء الذين يعملون في
الفنادق والملاهي الترفيهيه من خلفه
تاريخيا كانوا يصلون للديموقراطيين هذه
الولايه صوتت في انتخابات عام 2012 للرئيس
اوباما عام 2016 للمرشح الى رجلين وفي
انتخابات عام 2020 للرئيس لكن الرئيس هو
نقطه الضعف التي يعاني منها ديمقراطيون في
هذه الانتخابات تحديدا في هذه الولايه
التي تعاني من التضخم لاسيما فيما يتعلق
باسعار الوقود وهذا ما يحاول ان يدفع به
الجمهوريون للنيل عمليا هذه الورقه
الرابعه في الولايه وبالتالي الانظار
مسلطه على نيفادا في هذه اللحظات ال سي
تصفر عنه نتائج الانتخابات نشكرك من
نيفادا مراسلنا فادي منصور
في وجهه المشهد الانتخابي تبرز جدليه
المحافظه على البيئه ومحاربه التغيير
المناخي والتوجه الى الاعتماد على طاقه
نظيفه في مقابل الضغوط التي يولدها ارتفاع
اسعار الطاقه الاحفوريه وما يتبع ذلك من
اثر الاقتصادي يشهد هذا الملف القساما بين
المرشحين الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين محمد
الاحمد يرصد لنا هذا الجدل في ولايه باريس
منور منور
نتيجه استخراج الوقود الاحفوري المدعومي
من الجمهوريين وشركات الطاقه النافذه
يعملوا ان تتحول ولايته وهي من اهمه منتجي
الفحم والغاز نحو الطاقات النظيفه وهي
اولويه لبيض والديمقراطيين لكنه يرى ان
هذا الهدف لا يزال بعيد
لا اعتقد ان الطاقات البديله فعاله اذ يجب
ايجاد ملكيه لوضع اطنان من الالواح
الشمسيه بينما تغطي الاشجار الكثيفه الشمس
ويجب قطعها بالنسبه للملاك لا يمكن القيام
بذلك فضلا عن انه سيكلف اكثر من 37 الف
دولار وانا لا املك ذلك
اكبر منتج للغاز الطبيعي وثالثه اكبر منتج
للكهرباء في البلاد كما تملك ثلاث مصافي
بترول بانتاج يقارب 270 الف برميل يوميا
لكنها في نفس الوقت رابع ولايه مصدره
للانبعاثات الكربونيه
هنا تبرز الطاقه والمناخ قضيه رئيسيه بين
المتنافسين على انتخابات حاكم الولايه
ومقعد مجلس الشيوخ
فاديمقراطيه
وجون بيترمان يدعواني لعمليات التنقيب
المسؤوله مع تعزيز التوازن بين الغاز
الطبيعي وتوسيع الاستثمار في الطاقات
البديله وهو موقف تؤيده استطلاعات المحليه
في الاستفاده من فرص قانون الطاقه الاخير
لبعيد وتسريع الانتقال فعليا نحو نظام
طاقه نظيفه ومستدامه والحفاظ على الموارد
المائيه لذا فان التناقض قوي مع النهج
الجمهوري وهذا يظهر جليا بين المرشحين
اما المرشحان الجمهوريان ضد مصريان وميمي
رفع القيود على التنقيب في الاراضي
الفيدراليه بهدف تحقيق الاستقلال في
الطاقه وزياده التصدير بالنسبه لكريستفر
وهو نائب مهتم بامن الطاقه فيرى ان القضيه
باتت اكثر الحاحا في ضوء تاثيرات الحرب
الروسيه على اسعار الوقود المحليه
فقد كانت تذكيرا بشان الاعتماد على دول
روسيا في النفط والغاز لم يكن ذلك ما حل
تفكير للعموم في الماضي لكنه فتح الان
اعين العالم على اهميه امن الطاقه
اولوياته فقد وقع في اغسطس الماضي قانون
الاستثمار 370 مليار دولار
ان خطته للتحول نحو الطاقات النظيفه لكنها
تصطدم بالوضع العالمي حيث الطالب على
النفط والغاز يزداد داخليا وخارجيا
لا شك ان السيطره على الكونغرس تحدد
سياسات المناخ والطاقه خلال العامين
المقبلين فسيطره الديمقراطيين ستعزز
طموحات بيض للانتقال نحو الطاقات الخضراء
اما فوز الجمهوريين فسيكرس استمرار الوقود
الاحفوري مصدرا اساسيا للطاقه محمد احمد
الجزيره بن سلمان
حول هذا الموضوع معنا في الاستوديو كاليف
لهاوس كبيره الباحثين والمحرره السياسيه
لشؤون الحكم الرشيده في معهد التونسي
ومعنى ايضا في الاستوديو الدكتور ادوارد
جوزف المسؤول السابق في اللجنه الوطنيه
للحزب الديمقراطي مرحبا بكما كاليف سنبدا
معكي اذا كان الجمهوريون يؤيدون رفع
القيود على التنقيب عن الطاقه ما هو
جوابهم عن انعكاسات ذلك على البيئه في ظل
الازدياد الشواهد في الولايات المتحده على
انعكاسات التغير المناخي
عايزين
حتى يضغط بالنسبه الى موضوع تغيير
المناخيه ووضع المزيد من القيود على انتاج
الطاقه من غاز ووقود قبل هذه المرحله ولكن
بسبب العقوبات التي فرضت على روسيا بعد
الحرب التي قامت بها وايضا بسبب ازمه
الطاقه في اوروبا فكل ذلك سبب ارتفاع
اسعار النفط والغاز هنا في الولايات
المتحده وهذا ابرز ما يفكر به الناخبون
الان للاسف لا يفكرون بتغير المناخ
ما رايك ما هو الاكثر الحاحا الان الحفاظ
على البيئه والتفكير في الطاقه النظيفه ام
توفير هذه الطاقه في ظل الازمه العالميه
نحن ليس لدينا ترف ان نختاره الاولويات
القصيرات الامد بدون ان نفكره بالاولويات
الطويله الامل بسببين اولا
يجب ان نتصدى او نعالج ازمه تراجع الانتاج
بسبب
اجتياح رسلي اوكرانيا
ولكن ايضا بالمنافسه التي تاتينا من الصين
في مجال الطاقه المتجدده لقد راينا الخطر
حين تكون اوروبا تعتمد على روسيا اكثر من
اللازم في مجال الطاقه ولكن ايضا نحن
نعتمد على الصين في التكنولوجيا وانتاجه
كل ما له علاقه بمصادر الطاقه المتجدده
وعلينا ان نطور هذا المجال بانفسنا هذا
ليس خيار بينما يمكن ان نقول به الان
ولاحقا يجب ان نظمنا ان نقطتين وهذا ما
سمعناه في تقرير ان ديمقراطيه في فرنسا
عن سياسه مسؤوله طبعا نحن نعترف بالحاجه
الى الاستمرار في الانتاج لكن نبقي اعيننا
على الطاقه المتجدده
الموضوع ليس فقط الحفاظ على البيئه بقدر
ما هو ايضا
التنفس مع الصين في هذا المجال مجال
الطاقه النظيفه
وانا اوافق تماما على ضروره اعتمادي
مقاربه مسؤوله ولكن للاسف يبدو انا اوروبا
سوف تدخل في مرحله ركودا الان وبالتالي
الموارد التي يمكن ان نخصصها لتعزيز مجال
المصادر الطاقه المتجدده خساره اقل مما
كانت عليه قبل الحرب وتضخم بسببها اعتقد
ان معظم مواردنا الان سوف تكون من اجل
الحفاظ على الوقود الاحفوري وكذلك النوويه
وكذلك
التركيز على او اولويه تعزيز الطاقه
المتجدده قد يكون عليها او يق- يكون علينا
تاجيلها الان للاسف
باعتقادك هذا المنطقه الذي تحدث به عن انه
يجب القيام بكل شيء بالتوازي الى اين مدى
سيجد صدام لدى الناخب الناخب الذي يشعر
بازمه الطاقه الان
[موسيقى]
ينظرون الى كل
قصير ينظرون الى اسعار الوقود عند المحطات
30 سنه للجالون الواحد
اجوال ب 24
الاسعار بعد اجتياح روسيا لاوكرانيا سوف
يفكرون فانهم يدفعون سعرا اعلى من قبل
وهذا لا يسعدم طبعا هذا سوف يؤثر على
تصويتهم هناك الكثير من استطلاعات الراي
التي ابرزت ان الناخبين الامريكيين
بعدد كبير يدركنا اهميه التغير المناخيه
وكذلك موضوع تقدم الصين في هذا المجال سوف
نرى خلال الانتخابات التجديد النصفي اذا
كان الجمهوريون الذين يصلون الى الكونغرس
سوف يقاربون هذا الموضوع وكيف سيقاربون
موضوع الشرق الاوسط لاسيان مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وعلاقاتهم معها حيث ان
سعوديه خفضت الانتاج
بمليوني برميل في اليوم
ليس واضح كيف
الموقف الجمهوري
عندما يبرز الكونغرس الجديد
المسؤول السابق في اللجنه الوطنيه للحزب
الديمقراطي والسيده كاليف لا هاوس
الباحثين والمحرر السياسيه لشؤون الحكومه
والامن القومي في معهد كونسي شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا بهذا وصلنا الى نهايه نافذتنا من
واشنطن عوده الان الى حسن في الدوحه
[موسيقى]
اقيم في كنيسه اللقاء بضاحيه بيت حنينا
شمال القدس المحتله قداسون دعت اليه عائله
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله بعد عمليه نصف عام
على اغتيالها ياتي ذلك في وقت تتواصل فيه
الجهود محليا ودوليا لتحقيق العداله
لشيرين حيث تواصلوا شبكه الجزيره جهودها
من اجل محاسبه الجنان
وتقدمت نقابه الصحفيين الفلسطينيين
والاتحاد الدولي للصحافيين ومنظمات حقوقيه
وكذلك سلطه الفلسطينيه بشكاوي للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
ومحاسبه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد ان اثبتت
كافه التحقيقات انها شيرين ابو عقله قتلت
برصاص جنود الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
تمضي الايام ولا يمضي الحزن
وكانه الصمت المستحيل يحول غياب شيرين الى
حضور مستمر
في القدس في مدينتها الاحد الى قلبها اقيم
قداس نصف العام لراحت نفسها التي قد تتحقق
ايضا بتحقيق عدالتها وعداله شعبها وهو ما
كانت تتمنى
شيرين الصحفيين الفلسطينيين من مواصله
عملهم والتغطيه من قلب الميدان لكن ذلك لا
يبدد مشاعر الخوف لديهم من مواجهه ذات
المصير ليس من منطلق ضعف بل بسبب عدم
مسائله القاتل الذي يدرك ان بامكانه تكرار
ذلك
بعيدا عن المحاسبه
كانت محاكمه قتله شيرين ستحقق نوعا من
الحمايه لباقي الصحفيين الفلسطينيين في
الميدان لكنها لم تحدث ومع هذه العداله
الغائبه بواصل الجنود الاحتلال الاعتداء
على الصحفيين بما في ذلك قتلهم
تماما كما قتلت الزميل غفران وراسني
مباشره بعد اغتيال شيرين
وهذا ايضا ما عايشه الزملاء من تلفزيون
فلسطين قبل مده وجيزه
في لحظه رفع السلاح في وجهنا كان هناك
شعور
بانتهاء كل شيء عندي في لحظه معينه يعني
مر في ذهني الكثير من المشاهد منها مشهد
جريمه قتل شيرين
بالسدادات وهذا يؤكد نتائج سلسله تحقيقات
افضل الى ان استهداف شيرين كان متعمدا على
عكس روايه الاحتلال بل رواياته المتعدده
والمتغيره
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين وندل على ذلك بعدد ال- همم
الجرائم التي ترتكب بشكل يومي ضد الصحفيين
وبالتالي هذه السياسه المؤمنهجه
المقرر من الحكومه الاسرائيليه نعتبرها
حرب واسعه النطاق ضد الصحفيين الفلسطيني
ين على انها حرب على الروايه الفلسطينيه
في مسعا للتعتيم على جرائم الاحتلال فمن
يخشى الحقيقه
يقتل صوت الحق
الجزيره القدس المحتله
[موسيقى]
تصعيدا النظام السوري ميدانيا وتدهور
الاوضاع الانسانيه في شمال سوريا فما هي
تفاصيل الساعه الاخيره
في وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم الاحد سقط قتلى
بينهم اطفال وعشرات الجرح جرى قصف لقوه
النظام بالصواريخ طالما مخيمات عشوائيه
للنازحين في شمال غرب سوريا
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن الدفاع المدني انا
قوات النظام السوري استخدمت في هجومها
صواريخا
وتسيطر فصائل معارضه على نحو مصر مساحه
ادلب ومناطق محدوده محازيه من محافظات
حماه وحلب واللاذقيه وتؤري المنطقه ثلاثه
ملايين شخص نحو نصفهم من النازحين
وتشهدوا مدينه ادلب اتفاقا لوقفه اطلاق
النار تواصلت اليه المعارضه والنظام
السوري في مارس اذار من عام 2020
برعايه روسيه تركيه
الا ان المنطقه تتشهد بين الحين والاخر
قصفا متبادلا تشنها اطراف عده كما تتعرض
لغارات من جانب قوات النظام وروسيا رغم ان
وقفه اطلاق النار لا يزال صامدا الى حد
كبير ماذا عن التكلفه الانسانيه لذلك
وثقت لقطات مصوره حركه النزوح من مخيم
مرام بريف ادلب الغربي شمال سوريا بعد قصف
بصواريخ تحمل رؤوسا عنقوديه مصدرها قوه
النظام السوري وروسيا استهدفت سته مخيمات
فجر الاحد
وتظهر اللقطات المصوره بدا مدنيين بجمع
امتعتهم للرحيل من الخيام التي نزحوا
اليها بعد ان سقطت قنابل عن قضيهم ادت الى
مقتل 9 مدنيين وجرح اكثر من 70
كما اثار تالقطاته اثار الدمار في الخيام
التي تعرضت للقصف ودماء الناجحين وبقايا
طعامهم وامتعتهم وخيامهم الممزقه
المدنيه والسوريه طلبا مجتمع الدولي
بايجاد صيغه تضمن توقف روسيا والنظام
السوريه عن الاستهداف المنهج للسكان في ظل
عدم التزامهم باي اطار يدعم عمليه الحل
السياسي كما طلب الائتلاف الوطني السوري
بانعقاد عاجل لمجلس الامن واتخاذ اجراءات
عقابيه ضد مرتكبي المجازر المستمره بحق
الشعب السوري
من اسطنبول
معنا وائل علوان الباحث في مركز جسور
للدراسات مرحبا بك سيد علوان لماذا تجدد
القصف على خيام النازحين في ادلب كما حصل
فجر اليوم اي هدف سياسي او عسكري من وراء
ذلك
نعم تحياتي لكم بالفعل مجزره كبيره ثلاثه
اطفال وامراه بين القتل التسعه الذين
سقطوا والعدد من القتلى قابل للزياده حيث
السبعين جريحا بينهم حالات خطيره الرساله
واضحه من النظام النظام يحاول الضغط على
تركيا بالملف الانساني في موضوع اللاجئين
وانتم تعلمون ان في مقدمه اهداف تركيا في
مفاوضاتها الاخيره مع النظام والتي ترعاها
روسيا هي موضوع عوده اللاجئين وضمان عدم
تجدد موجات النزوح
المفاوضات ما بين النظام وما بين تركيا
ضمن الوساطه الروسيه هي مفاوضات صعبه
ومتعثره اليوم هناك مطالب مختلفه طبعا
النظام يطالب بان يكون له وصول الى ادلب
يطالب بفتح المعابر التجاريه بشكل كامل
دون ان يقدم لتركيا ضمانات حقيقيه في
ايقاف دعمه لمن تصفهم تركيا بالمجموعات
الانفصاليه الارهابيه هناك مفاوضات معقده
بين النظام وبين تركيا تريد النظام ان
يضغط في الملف الحساس الذي تخشاه تركيا
وهو موضوع الحملات من النزوح كما ذكرتم ان
بعد هذا القصف على المخيم بالتحديد بدات
حملات من ااا ان النازحين يضربون امتعتهم
وينتقلون ينتقلون بالتاكيد الى منطقه اقرب
الى الحدود التركيه هذا ما سيشكل الضغط
انساني وسيمنع عوده اللاجئين من تركيا الى
سوريا فضلا عن انه قد يخلق مع استمرار هذا
التصعيد موجات من اللجوء ومن محاولات
اللاجئين الفراعنه اذا كان النظام
على تركيا
ماذا يريد من مكاسب مباشره همم من هذا
الضغط
نعم طبعا ضمن الوساطه الروسيه
للمباحثات والمفاوضات التي تجري بين تركيا
والنظام يريد نظام خلق منفذ له منفذ
اقتصادي منفذ حتى في موضوع تجاوز العقوبات
الامريكيه عن طريق مناطق المعارضه التي
تدعمها تركيا يريد النظام فتح المعابر
التجاريه من ادلب ومن غيرها من المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها المعارضه وان يكون هناك
قدره تجاريه يستفيد منها النظام من
البضائع التي تدخل من تركيا وممكن ان تصدر
سواء الى خارج سوريا او في مختلف المناطق
في سوريا ومنها مناطق سيطره قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه التي تخشى تركيا من استمرار
دعم قوات النظام لها في المواجهات التي
تدور ما بينها وبين تركيا اذا النظام
اليوم ينظر الى موضوع المفاوضات مع تركيا
على انها فرصه فضلا عن ان روسيا رغم
هماتها الكبيره مع تركيا اليوم خاصه في
الملفات الاقليميه عموما لكنها الى اليوم
لم تصل الى تفاهمات نهائيا حول ادلب طيب
هنا هل تركيا برايك بورد ان تستجيب لما
يطلبه النظام كي لا تتلقى مزيدا من الضغط
بالملف الانساني
طبعا تركيا لديها اولويات في موضوع
التفاوض مع النظام هذه الاولويات في
مقدمتها موضوع الانخراط الجاد من النظام
في موضوع مكافحه الارهاب وهذا الامر مستعد
كما تعلمون النظام لا يستطيع ان يكون ضامن
لعدم انخراطه بشكل كامل في دعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني شمال شرق سوريا فضلا عن ان
يكون همم شريك لتركيا في موضوع كف هذا
التنظيم عن همم سيطرته على منظمات تابعه
له ضمن قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هذا اولويه
بالنسبه لتركيا وهذا من المستبعد ان يحصل
شكرا شكرا لكم العنوان الباحث في مركز
جسور للدراسات من الصمت
[موسيقى]
ازمه قبلات سواحل ايطاليا سفن تحمل ما
يقرب من 1000 طالب تنتظر في البحر لاكثر
من اسبوع تنتظر تصريحا بالرسوم من الحكومه
اليمنيه التي تولت السلطه الشهر الماضي
في بناء كتانيا
والاشخاص الذين يحتاجون الى رعايه طبيه
لكنها لن تسمح لسفن اخرى تحمله
في ضوء تعهد الحكومه الايطاليه الجديده
لتشديد الاجراءات لمنع قوارب طالب اللجوء
المنطلقه من شمال افريقيا الى اوروبا كان
الله في عون الجميع
[موسيقى]